how important is story analysis for a
screenwriter I think it's the main way
to learn screenwriting I think it's
actually more important than writing
okay maybe that's because I uh worked as
a reader on the job for studios and
production companies and I learned so
much on the job but I think forcing
yourself to take apart a script or a
movie or a TV show and do written
analysis forcing yourself to write down
an analysis of it
and for some
reason just gives you a better learning
experience than just if you watch a
movie and you say oh okay I can see that
it's in four acts and there was a big
midpoint but if you force yourself to
really analyze it on paper I think it
really really helps how much do you
think new screenwriters realize this
don't they think that it's just an
innate talent and and I have these
Amazing Stories in my head all that
doesn't matter I need to get my story
out well I mean there's the some people
say just writing is the best thing you
can do write write write write as many
scripts as possible and yes that's great
but you can't write in a vacuum you know
you need to get notes from friends and
people who know scripts you know in the
industry um it's absolutely key that you
get notes um and I don't I think Talent
you know quote
Talent is maybe a part of it I think
it's just I don't know if we even call
it Talent it's just a proclivity towards
expressing yourself with the written
word and then uh can you do it in
screenplay format maybe there's a
certain ability there that's kind of
innate some people just can't get it and
some people it comes second nature but
the myth that you know great writers are
just born and they just type out their
first screenplay and it's genius I mean
that's a total myth you know you it's a
lot of practice it's a lot of work it's
a lot of Craft um it takes a while what
are the first steps to analyzing a story
for me what I call the basic story map
is you want to Define your foundational
elements to the narrative and that's
things like your protagonist their
internal and external goals the
obstacles in the way of those goals your
theme you know which is what is it about
why are you telling this story um there
certain characters like a shadow
character antagonist Ally those kind of
things and then how are you going to end
it um what is going to be the ending of
the story hopefully you know ahead of
time sometimes you don't but hopefully
you do and those once you've decided on
those elements that informs then how
you're going to beat out the story you
know the plot of the story but you need
those foundational elements to begin how
much to encourage new writers to analyze
other stories not their own so they're
because maybe they think oh I just want
to be focused on my story that's all I
care about but to really dissect and
reverse engineer someone else's story
that's a huge part of learning uh any
kind of writing um especially
screenwriting for movies and film
because it's so structure-based
um you want to analyze uh good scripts
and bad scripts I mean as a reader I
learn just as much from the bad scripts
as I did from the good ones because it
shows you what not to do do um and you
just get a sense of like oh that's not
working on the page um you know or
here's what it looks like when act one
goes on too long um so yeah doing story
analysis taking apart existing movies
existing TV shows it also helps to get a
kind of template show for yours like
let's say let's say you wanted to write
a seral killer thriller so maybe dissect
seven and the Silence of the Lamb maybe
something more recent and um use one of
those as your basic structural template
on your first pass and then when you
rewrite you can change that up but it
helps to just say okay here's a
structural template for me here's an
example of kind of what I would want to
do so you find a film or a show that has
a similar tone maybe it targets a
similar audience and then it's
definitely similar
genre um and that will provide kind of a
initial road map for you do you take
notes when analyzing a story I don't
really take many notes as I'm reading it
for the first time um I'm usually
reading uh on my computer on a PDF and I
embed notes in the PDF for my clients um
and my students and so the first pass I
don't note that much but then the second
pass I will embed notes in there you
know I just insert notes into
Adobe and um what I'd like to do is give
them my impression as a reader as I'm
reading it so since I know from being a
pro reader I want them to know what I'm
thinking at that time what is the reader
thinking so like oh okay this moment on
page 12 I don't understand it it's I'm
confused and then page 15 oh I see what
you were going for now but I want them
to have both of those notes so they know
that even though on page
they uh they resolved it or maybe they
had the payoff on page 12 the reader was
confused you know so I want them to have
my you know quote live reactions as I
read through something and those notes
will be something emailed and also
verbally gone over with like a phone or
an inperson session yeah usually we have
a follow-up Zoom call um if they're a
coaching client we do weekly zooms and I
just share my screen with the PDF and we
go over for them uh Page by Page whereas
as a reader in the past when you in a
prior interview we talked about your
prior time as a reader for Studio
scripts that was never something that
would happen it was only just a a pass
or a recommend it yeah it was a coverage
report which was like three to five
pages and you do um you kind of list the
the major things like length and author
and who submitted it and stuff and you
have a little box score excellent good
Fair por with different elements then
you summarize it then you do one page of
notes only and then you give your
recommendation whether it's a pass
consider or recommend how will thinking
like a script reader benefit a
screenwriter putting yourself in the
position of the reader I think is key um
you want to know that the reader is
going to be clear on what you're writing
you can't 100% know uh on your first
pass whether something is going to be
total toally clear to the reader that's
why you want to have other people read
it but you want to think to yourself if
this was a cold reader who didn't know
the story who didn't know me and they
were reading this for the first time is
it going to be clear the way it's
flowing on the page um another thing
like for example you don't want to have
super thick description paragraphs you
know like 12 lines of text in a
description paragraph because that
basically pisses off the reader you know
they're like God there's so much Tex on
the page it's like black ink everywhere
like they want it to flow and they want
it to uh you know basically go faster so
it doesn't take a lot more time to read
your script than it does another script
so I think reading scripts that's
another reason why you want to read in
other other scripts is you figure out uh
what can be annoying to a reader what
can hamper the process you know that's
why I think anyone does this and I
learned this when I was a reader the
first thing you do when you get a script
is you check how many pages it is you
know so if you're getting a movie script
um and it's like 135 Pages they're like
oh man this reader they're writing this
writer they're writing too much um they
really need an editor this you don't
want to have a script be that long
unless it's like an epic and then it's
like well you should be a established
Pro or something like that you know
scripts used to be 120 Pages was the
Target now they're more kind of like 100
to 110 you know maybe like 105 is The
Sweet Spot maybe go up to
115 um but it's those cues to the reader
it's how long is it um how long is each
Act you know how long does it take
before you have a really strong Catalyst
and the through line kicks in and the
engine kicks in you know um and reading
scripts will help you get in that
mindset so is it where you kind of have
to know the system and be quote part of
the system in order to figure out what
the system wants or what might even
surpass what's some of the material out
there I'm just thinking of people that
would be like you know I don't really
enjoy Hollywood I don't want to be part
of it so therefore I don't want to have
to think like a member of Hollywood yeah
no matter what uh budget level you're
working at whether it's indie or Studio
people still need to read that script
and they need to understand it and feel
the tone and the flow and it needs to be
clear
you're even if you're raising the funds
yourself and you're shooting it
independently you still need to give it
to actors you still need to give it to
crew members if you want a really good
DP well they're going to have to read it
too so it has to be clear and make sense
on the
page it if you want to do your own thing
um that's okay but just remember that
you still need to attract people to your
project okay so this reader quote
unquote is not a litmus test for
Hollywood it's does another human being
understand what's happening with the
story yeah I think that's probably the
best thing to uh the best way to think
about it and you don't want to psych
yourself out and think oh Hollywood
readers think this so I'm going to
change this you know you still want to
follow your gut and tell the story how
you want to tell the
story